[Music]
what's up [ __ ]
our leave the [ __ ] judging everyone
left and right inviting you to do the
same as well let us know if you like
this below we'll keep on doing it
alright this one guys says am I the
[ __ ] for pointing out to my friends
they are not famous there's so many
times where I need to tell somebody
there they're not famous okay wait I
have a perfect story this machine grinds
me up so I have a friend of mine that
has like half a million followers on
Instagram she's pretty popular she was
like she has a really big YouTube
channel I mean yeah sure you're probably
about like you know slowly rolls so we
were in a bowling alley one time and she
was like gosh I just realized this is
all my demographic I hope nobody
recognizes young and I was like okay
whatever and we're at the bar and I
literally turn my head and right through
the window I see Wanda Sykes on the
other side of the bar just drinking not
worried about getting recognized totally
fine and I was like right after she said
that I was like dude is that Wanda Sykes
we were friends with this girl
a youtuber person and she was like I
can't even go to the mall because it
just turns to a meet-and-greet okay yeah
seriously said she really said that I
used it in a movie yeah oh my [ __ ]
god
that's hikes or others movies on
internet famous and literally verbatim
quoted us yeah well maybe they should go
to the mall right here call Santa Anita
where it's a bunch of Chinese people yes
true is really nice mall I new tuber who
put on the back of his head shot people
at blah blah blah is the most popular
entertainer in the world with more views
than Jay Leno Brad Pitt Brad Pitt
[ __ ] David Letterman everyone more
famous than Brad Pitt nobody said that
combined combined oh yeah oh and and I
one time posited to him I like literally
made his brain do a full reboot because
I was like hey man don't you think it's
interesting that you had
billions like billions of views like
almost as many people on earth exist as
have seen your videos and yet Hollywood
does not call you mm-hmm yeah did not
know what the [ __ ] this and this person
made an exit video a few years later
saying that they're leaving YouTube
because they already dominated the game
and that they're gonna go take over
Hollywood it doesn't work like that it
just does it
alright guys you're [ __ ] delusional I
love that though I love minute-to-minute
yes being that I have to say about this
but all I'll roll into this yeah yes
fake reality let's find out this size
my friends are dating there are also
actors who have had small roles when a
few TV shows I'm talking two lines or
less I say this not to be a hater
I'm truly moving for them but to give
you a scope of the reach neither of them
have a following in real life or on
social media
they've got under 1,500 followers
combined anyway last week I posted a
group picture on Instagram of people
celebrating a friend's birthday everyone
in the photo has got their arms around
each other's shoulders just very
platonic
so anyways yesterday in a group chat
between the three of us they asked me to
take the photo down because they don't
want the public to know that they're
dating I would consider it if they look
bad or to sloppy drunk etc but they
don't
everyone has their arms around each
other not just them anyway I asked what
they meant and they said they didn't
want to end up in gossip rags I pointed
out that they are not famous and they
don't even have functioning IMDB page
and we don't think we're famous yeah
they were livid and called me a bunch of
names I think they're delusional but
they've been texting me and demanding it
and even sent me screenshots of them
reporting it nothing has happened at
this point I don't even want to be their
friend however and probably because I'm
an [ __ ] I don't want to delete it
slowly blade based on principle good for
you I love this person so what are their
numbers to need less than 1,500 combines
combined combined I know dogs that have
more [ __ ] followers than that gram
don't say that Joe dogs have hundreds of
millions of followers my house has 7,000
followers but I mean dude I feel like
this happens so much is that like
multiple platforms it's under 1500 and a
two together the tube to to mind come on
this is a girl at the when I was working
at the law firm that told me that I had
to take the posts down or not to take
her picture because her manager needs to
reviews it review any endorsement she
does and I was like [ __ ] it was
literally like a boomerang where it was
like this this much down of her yeah
people are delusion did you say oh
really
you don't want me to tag you with my
hundreds of thousands of followers I
won't do it oh it's fine it's fine it's
totally fine it for you the funny thing
is I know so many people that are
actually like super popular and they
don't even vocalize this it's not an act
do not insecure about it's really weird
because if you really were famous you
wouldn't have to talk about being famous
never famous or usually what they call
now the micro influencer or whatever
they are the ones getting of everyone a
bad rap be like demanding things for
free from like restaurants and hotels
being like do you know who I am
I mean I can make a post about this and
like you know those those be debris how
are you yeah can I just get this for
free like Do You Know Who I am I haven't
you exposure to 15,000 people and like
not even mentioning that half of them
are in New York and Texas hey you're
gonna get angry when they don't get free
[ __ ] from places do over the past
weekend I was at this
invention called like animate impulse so
like we had a booth there we meaning me
and Nelson stab booth was there and we
were selling wrist wraps right and
there's this like 8 year old kid that
was like looking at checking it out and
he was interested in it and then his mom
comes over I was like oh hey
my son is an influencer can we like
maybe work something out with this oh no
way and the mom pops up like the
freaking with his like kids Instagram
page he has like 40,000 followers and an
Elsa was like oh I don't know let me
take a look at it right looks like the
kids profile page I was like yeah 1
don't want to deal with it because like
he's actual response yeah because he was
looking at the you think it's full
engagement stuff right and then like the
kid barely had like like I don't know 40
likes on the photo when you the
followers robot yeah so then the mom was
just like yeah you know like maybe you
know as influencer you know you work
something out maybe take a couple photos
or whatever you know for the for the
problem everything say that maybe
worried something out I always think
like is this kid gonna suck somebody's
dick exactly like a pimp oh we had an
uber driver that got like when we got in
he was like raving about the person that
was just in the over before us and he
was like yo I just drove this kid he had
he's famous as [ __ ] on Instagram oh my
god he's like if you guys do have you
heard of this kid he pulls up the
Instagram the kid has thirty four
thousand followers and he's like you Oh
lookey he just takes picture of money
all day and that's funny
yo have you oh he was in this car in
yeah oh my god he's like he's like yeah
he's like I started screaming and crying
I'm gonna try to get on his level cuz
he's like he was telling me how he liked
by his money and you like he liked by
his money he buys fake money and you
takes pictures of it and they post
pictures and he's famous I wanna do that
I'm like you should do that is crazy
I'm gonna follow that kid right now what
is it oh my [ __ ] god
okay so something that I deal with like
that I that I have dealt with a lot at
work is I I deal with a lot of youtubers
and podcasters and I have this one
client that is so [ __ ] demanding
they're they're so [ __ ] demanding and
they alternate just a little Instagram
and they pretty good little tiny venues
and I'm just like
alrighty on but I had to explain to
somebody because sometimes we have
artists that have millions of followers
and like they don't do that well and the
good selling live shows yeah like
tickets and stuff and so what I had the
best way I could explain it to my boss
is that somebody like Drew Barrymore has
a household network of 250 millions
maybe 500 million people that when you
say drew Barrymore they know exactly who
she is but on Instagram she's got 4
million followers but her network is
let's say 500 million but then there's
these influencers that have 5 million
and that's it their network is 5 million
there it is not 200 million and is not
500 million so there are so many people
that are there their manes are such a
legacy but these influencers they see oh
my god I have my followers and Beyonce I
have more followers than drew Barrymore
a lot and and they and they just they're
like the numbers there that's a quite
fame with followers yeah they're like
facts and logic right here numbers boom
roasted and so I have to sit back and
like explain to them like yes sure they
have two million but that's it that's
all that they have if I go out to the
mall any other name absolutely no one
knows who they are but when you have
people that have a like a network
outside of the digital space it's like a
totally different day and like the
influencers just don't [ __ ] get it
they don't understand that at all but
then the real world legacy - right like
people with household names that don't
really go on social media anymore but
you know like who they are and then on
the inverse side at work that's so weird
you know it's weird - is it the on the
inverse side the famous guys like the
biggest star of the world right now like
like the Mark Wahlberg's and the Chris
Pratt's not sure they don't know how the
[ __ ] to use social media so like like
they don't know that when they post a
youtube show the reason why it doesn't
get any views is because people don't
feel like
them and that's mostly why people are
not in case we're not engaged with the
people I mean Jack Black is doing well
well yeah why why those doing it when
you watch when you watch those guys it's
very personable and they're doing it
like a youtuber they're not doing
something yeah I think Will Smith is
doing it to flex to be like oh this is
hot right now all right I could do this
so but he still passes as being
relatable available yeah got but it's
well this mother fire will you buy it
I'm like well to lookee he's with his
wife out with my husband I'm a
Scientologist he's a Scientologist I
have a billion dollars here's a billion
dollars make me a my black wife have an
open relationship
oh wait none of that's real about me
damn it all right guys question who's
more famous laelia ponds or Oprah
Winfrey Oprah who's the first one many
ponds but depends on who you ask
if you ask a ten-year-old maybe Laila
yeah who's Oprah
well why though worldwide though
worldwide it's got to be Oprah oh my you
played the Super Bowl and a bunch of
kids were like who's this old guy
playing guitar yeah and okay and how
many followers do you see who do you
think has more followers I don't know I
say Lele pons mom lon on Instagram yeah
yeah mr. Graham yeah so Oprah Winfrey
has o-over Winfrey has 17 million
followers pretty good pretty good
Lele pons has 38 million yeah Empire
dude Oprah is I like it's a legacy and
owns acres of land in Maui and also
other places so imagine imagine Lele
pons saying I'm more famous than Oprah
Winfrey just based off those numbers in
any like young person might be like yeah
but she is in numbers those numbers
don't mean shares a litmus test if
Instagram were to be deleted today how
famous would you be oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
[ __ ] and people also don't account for
like in the influencer Network it's like
not even always about how many followers
you have who do you know who do you
actually know in the industry if
Instagram was deleted tomorrow could you
carry on your career you know who are
your friends who went to your wedding
who likes you
yeah who actually likes you yep oh [ __ ]
that's it you can't do no six second sex
kits anymore what are you gonna do dude
I have friendships on from the tubes cuz
I found the good ones that have lasted
for over a decade
and that that's rare because there's not
a lot of real people in this medium
unfortunately but the good ones in
entertainment hell yeah that's why we
keep to ourselves
JK like we always kept to ourselves and
we built our own [ __ ] and we made
friends with him attention bring out who
you really are and unfortunately for a
lot of people who they really are is
pretty narcissistic so that's how
there's a little bit of narcissist but
it's like you can either be a healthy
narcissist or you can be [ __ ] up
because I think the definition of
narcissism has been kind of skewed all
totally yeah same with like it was that
don't have empathy because they're just
so in selfishness yeah
[Music]